a primordial mother a Divine female who
births the first generation of deities
and Mesopotamian mythology Tiamat is
crucial to life and death Tiamat makes
up the salty Waters of creation the
ocean is known for its prolific capacity
to generate living organisms life is
born from the sea in the case of Tiamat
so are monsters this ancient
Mesopotamian goddess produced 11
different frightening beasts from
dragons to scorpion men but his team
ought herself really all that
frightening is the mother of monsters
even a monster
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
much of Mesopotamian mythology
attributes natural phenomena to
intelligent deities this becomes
particularly significant in relation to
rainfall since the Region's early
adoption of an irrigation agricultural
system defined its success and helped
secure the development of numerous
large-scale permanent settlements due to
soil conditions land could easily become
flooded and salinized making cultivation
challenging and presumably at the whim
of the Gods so it makes sense that one
of their Central myths would involve two
primordial bodies of water opsu source
of all fresh water and Tiamat the source
of all salt water tiamat's written
history begins around the second half of
the second millennium BCE in the enuma
Elish now commonly known as the
Babylonian epic of creation these
cuneiform tablets are the backbone of
Mesopotamian mythology her appearance on
this text is ambiguous it reveals she is
female but little else is known although
she is at least somewhat humanoid it
also indicates that she is made of water
this story gets a bit confusing so I
have this family tree to help us out the
language in the text suggests that the
primordial deities mingling involved
biological reproduction with opsu as
begetter and father of all and Tiamat as
the mother who births all from her womb
all of the original gods in the
Mesopotamian Pantheon are produced by
these two as their progeny in turn
procreate each God becomes more powerful
than the next ansar and kiss our son Anu
begot IA also known as nudimud IO was
the champion among his fathers god of
wisdom magic and water known for his
trickery and Mischief he and the other
gods amused themselves by making a
racket within tiamat's belly where they
lived one day IA overhears apsu who we
might consider his great-grandfather
complaining to Tiamat about their
children and suggesting that they be
killed horrified and angered Tiamat
refuses suggesting they take more
lenient disciplinary action which opsu
ignores es Slaughters opsu and uses his
body to create a new Dwelling Place
which is named opsu which is morbid AF
all of this is still in tiamat's womb by
the way patricide complete IA has his
own son mardok the strongest yet of the
Gods mardok is gifted with the power of
the Four Winds and uses them to stir up
a flood wave in tiamat's womb which
exacerbates all the other gods in a
colossal Act of retaliation either
motivated by revenge or insult depending
on interpretation Tiamat births 11
monsters into the world girl made an
army of kids ones with sharp teeth and
poison for blood giant serpents dragons
and raging dragons apparently there is a
distinction Harry hero men lion men
weather demons snakes scorpion men
fishmen bull men and the fantastically
ambiguous aggressive demons a bit
panicked by this influx of Creations the
other gods Grant Marduk the power to
create and Destroy eof further equips
his son with a scepter thrown staff and
other weaponry Marduk makes a bow calls
up some winds and Thunderbolts and
readies for battle Marduk provokes
Tiamat with insults and she launches
into a hasty attack leaving herself
vulnerable
she is captured in a net and overwhelmed
by the winds before marduk's Arrow
pierces her stomach tearing her open
he manages to subdue her monstrous
children before returning to Tiamat
crushing her skull with a mace and
slitting her arteries open Marduk uses
one half of her dead body to form the
heavens and the other to craft the Earth
from her eyes he creates the Euphrates
and Tigris Rivers from her breasts he
makes mountains what is left of her
becomes the oceans he traps tiamat's
monstrous Offspring At His Feet informs
images of them to place at the entrance
of the dwelling opsu to remind the world
of their existence the Tiamat story can
be better understood by looking at
earlier seemingly disparate mythologies
that all Blended together to create our
monster mother's story remember how
Tiamat birthed 11 monsters to avenge her
partner's death well that number pops up
in other older Mesopotamian lore like
the tale of nanerta an ancient Sumerian
Warrior God associated with agriculture
who slew 11 enemies before designing the
world and two Sumerian texts from the
late 3rd millennium BCE contain a list
of monster kin eerily similar to those
attributed to Tiamat and how many were
there 11. then there are monstrous
deities associated with the tumultuous
sea such as the Canaanite Yang gendered
masculine he is described as both a
serpent and a dragon with seven heads
depending on the source able to wield
chaotic power like Tiamat yam is
defeated by a heroic young God Baul
Tiamat herself appears by name in an
evocation as patron of a fierce warrior
in a text from Central Mesopotamia
around 2350 BCE still nothing in the
Canaanite or Sumerian narratives suggest
Tiamat would be a monster just a
powerful God her great power is admired
and feared but with respectful reverence
more than outright horror a potentially
monstrous God rather than strictly a
monster but what would make something a
monster by Sumerian or Acadian standards
well there was no singular word to
categorize fearsome creatures but their
monstrosity was marked in images and
texts by a combination of predatory
animal features like Teeth wings and
Claws this visual traits that would be
grafted onto Tiamat in the middle Bronze
Age and first Millennium Marduk was once
only a local God said to preside over
the city of Babylon his mythical status
grew along with the rise of Hammurabi
the sixth king of Babylon to help
solidify his control over the people of
the Dynasty and eventual rule over
almost all the peoples of Mesopotamia
the King used the Code of Hammurabi a
legal text which basically boils down to
the laws of Retribution marduk's defeat
of Tiamat came to represent the
installment of the real-life Babylonian
King onto the throne as the Victor over
so-called chaos Marduk or Bell as he
came to be known as The New National God
provided a mythological representation
of good over evil law over lawlessness A
fitting metaphor for King Hammurabi's
right to rule the myth of Tiamat and
marduk's great battle received a ritual
portrayal every year at a spring
agricultural festival called akitu In
the neo-babylonian period this would
become a New Year celebration that
lasted into the Hellenistic period after
that tiamat's story was largely lost to
time that was until the 19th century
when the enuma Elish was first
translated into English giving Tiamat
new prominence in popular culture
today's modern construction of Tiamat is
largely due to Canadian author and
clergyman George a Barton whose 1893
article dubbed Tiamat compares her to
the biblical serpent Leviathan and the
great red dragon of Revelations
most damnedly he describes her as a
female dragon queen of a hideous host
who were hostile to the Gods he goes as
far as to say that her apocalyptic
imagery indicates the popular
personification of hideousness arrogance
and evil even outside of this odd grab
bag of religious beliefs dude clearly
has it out for the primordial goddess
since then Tiamat was commonly painted
as demonic chaos as other Publications
adopted a negative view of her she
became even in her best light the bad
mother in the story when Tiamat is
adapted for popular culture today she
retains the evil dragon status in
Dungeons and Dragons Tiamat is not a
mother but a daughter The Offspring of
the Dragon Creator God IO as a
five-headed dragon she is said to be in
constant battle with her brother Bahamut
Final Fantasy also incorporates the
multi-headed dragon version into their
universe as well making Tiamat one of
the top level bosses although as the
franchise continued she loses more and
more heads if we look back at tiamat's
11 monsters it's possible to identify
precursors to mermaids or Sirens the
Minotaur Bigfoot or even whatever this
is all the members of tiamat's monstrous
brood are meant to be frightening
because of their animalistic qualities
or inherent malice unlike her other
Godly Offspring her monstrous children
were formed independently adding another
threatening mysterious layer to their
existence Tiamat is both nurturer and
Destroyer mother and monster as she
chooses after all Tiamat and every God
and monster she birthed offers A fitting
edible metaphor fear that our Creations
could someday not only overshadow us but
literally destroy us
I think I said ham let's go back do you
think that 11 from stranger things is 11
because of this whole like it would be
cool right 11 monsters that's my new
Theory